eso
[Música]
saben qué es lo que hacían las mujeres
en la casa blanca durante el gobierno de
obama para lograr ser escuchadas
ellas diseñaron una estrategia para
lograr posicionar sus ideas utilizaron
una técnica que se llama amplificación
es muy simple consiste en repetir una
idea una y otra vez hasta que sea
imposible dejarla de lado parte de la
amplificación es repetir siempre el
nombre de la autora de la de la idea
original para evitar que ésta sea
apropiada por otra porque es que a veces
lo que nos pasa es que nuestras ideas no
son tomadas en cuenta hasta que de
pronto pues las dice un hombre
esenciales la amplificación es poder
confiar en nuestras compañeras porque
nuestras ideas pueden ser muy buenas y
podemos repetirlas hasta el cansancio
pero es el eco de las que están ahí con
nosotras las que van a elevar las
posibilidades de que ésta sea acogida
pero tampoco es tan fácil no es cierto
esto es la confianza
este señor es schopenhauer y ahí por el
siglo 18 dijo que una mujer es la peor
enemiga de otra mujer lamentablemente
esta es una idea que todavía perdura
hasta el día de hoy por ejemplo es
probable que algunas de ustedes les
hayan dicho alguna vez que lo peor pero
lo peor que les puede pasar es tener una
jefa mujer
o qué tal esta otra las mujeres son las
peores machistas no solamente machistas
sino las peores como si hubiera algún
tipo de ranking o algo en lo que por fin
hubiéramos logrado quedar primeras
y es que si se ponen a pensar este
cuento en la rivalidad femenina nos lo
han ido contando una y otra vez saben
cuándo
antes de dormir con cuentos con cuentos
como por ejemplo el de blancanieves
blancanieves si lo piensan fríamente
blancanieves es la historia de una mujer
que es capaz de matar a otra mujer para
quedarse con el príncipe azul y ser la
más bella
si lo vemos así no nos puede llamar la
atención que haya decidido dejar su casa
a mudarse al bosque con siete
desconocidos antes de quedarse con la
única mujer en la con la que podía
contar
les quiero proponer dejar de lado esta
idea de la rivalidad femenina y en lugar
de eso empezar a hablar de sonoridad
han escuchado esa palabra
es linda no
en inglés es sisterhood y pueden
encontrar la definición en el
diccionario de off en español la verdad
todavía no decide incluirla pero eso no
significa que no tengamos una definición
la sororidad es la solidaridad entre
mujeres que propician la confianza y el
apoyo mutuo no se trata necesariamente
de que seamos amigas ni de que pensemos
igual ni de que estemos de acuerdo en
todo ni siquiera se trata de que nos
caigamos bien la solidaridad lo que nos
pide es que nos juntemos que formemos
alianzas para cambiar estas reglas de
fuego que fueron creadas o que no fueron
creadas por mí para nosotras pero que
nos afectan porque de muchas formas a
muchas de nosotras acá el ser mujer en
algún momento de nuestras vidas nos jugó
en contra
la sonoridad es también este sentimiento
que hizo que por primera vez algunas de
nosotras salgamos a la calle un 11 de
agosto de 2016 con una menos porque de
alguna manera nos dimos cuenta que lo
que le estaba pasando a una nos pasaba a
todas es también este sentimiento que
hizo que aquí y en muchas otras partes
del mundo digamos yo también yo también
fui acosada yo también fui violada yo
también fue golpeada
y seamos claras estamos en un evento
tetex de mujeres evidentemente algo nos
llama
tal vez es que ya estamos cansadas de
que nos acosen en el transporte público
y nadie haga nada
o que alguien nos arrastre del pelo por
el piso de un hotel y que dos años
después siga libre
o de que un congresista nos toque
mientras estamos trabajando y luego pide
que sea una demostración de los hechos y
que luego venga una siguiente persona a
decir de qué nos quejamos si esto pasa
todo el tiempo
pero también estamos cansadas de que nos
despidan porque estamos embarazadas o de
que nos pregunten en las entrevistas de
trabajo si pensamos tener hijos o
casarnos o de estar en pleno 2018 y
muchas veces seguir siendo las únicas
mujeres en las reuniones de trabajo y
también por supuesto estamos cansadas de
ganar en promedio 29 por ciento menos
que nuestros padres hombres
estas y otras cosas tienen que cambiar
yo les quiero contar un día hoy día como
las mujeres podemos generar cambios
cuando nos juntamos hoy les vengo a
contar la historia de week
wim son las siglas en inglés de mujeres
en la profesión legal esta es una
iniciativa del band center que es una
organización en nueva york' que promueve
entre muchas otras cosas la diversidad y
la inclusión en la profesión legal
trabajamos para generar cambios en las
reglas del juego pero también para
triunfar dentro de nuestros propios
ámbitos hoy día hay webs en 19 países y
es increíble como miles de mujeres no
necesitamos conocernos personalmente
unas a otras para generar cambios
algunas veces nos toca implementar
proyectos es muy perú por ejemplo y esto
sí han tenido lugar en chile o colombia
lo único que tenemos que hacer es
compactar a esa otra abogada que no
conocemos agendar una llamada y del otro
lado de la línea tenemos garantizados a
alguien que va a trabajar con nosotros
para impulsar nuestro proyecto no
importa que no la beneficie a ella
directamente ni a su organización porque
para nosotras cuando ayudamos a una nos
ayudamos todas
uy llega al perú en el 2016 cuando el
bank center contacta a natalie paredes y
fátima de romañá que son socias de dos
estudios de abogados y les propone
iniciar el capítulo peruano de wifi
ellas por supuesto aceptan
inmediatamente a su vez contactan a
otras ocho abogadas que también se suman
de inmediato y yo me unía a ellas un
poco después yo todavía recuerdo esa
primera reunión porque solo conocía a
una de las días que estaban ahí y
solamente entrar y empezar a escuchar la
de experiencias personales y
profesionales que se compartían un
impacto personalmente y esto porque yo
nunca he tenido una jefa mujer y de
hecho en mi experiencia profesional he
sido la única mujer en mi área por mucho
tiempo entonces tuvieron una serie de
vivencias o experiencias que me pasaban
por ser mujer y que nunca pude compartir
ni comentarle a nadie
uy cambio eso para mí y para muchas
otras abogadas mujeres de un momento a
otro este miedo de ir a una reunión
porque no conocemos a nadie o de no
saber cómo enfrentar comentarios
incómodos de clientes o de otros
abogados con los que trabajamos o el
sentirnos culpables porque tenemos un
embarazo complicado que nos obliga a
descansar y también el ir a pedir poco
más y perdón por tener un segundo hijo y
jurar que nunca más lo vamos a volver a
hacer
pero bueno somos abogadas y algunas
veces las capacidades síntesis no es
nuestra principal habilidad pero una de
nosotras tenía un envío
y porque les cuento esto porque una de
las principales características de which
es que nosotros no competimos no somos
rivales nos sumamos entonces esta bobada
que tiene el envié y nos llevó a un
taller de design thinking que era algo
muy nuevo para muchas de nosotras
estábamos todas llenas de post-its
ella logró que lo que transformaremos
este ímpetu de lluvia de ideas en 43
ideas principales
nada más luego están las volvimos cinco
líneas de trabajo que después pasaron a
formar cinco comités cada una dedicada a
una problemática específica y es que nos
comenzamos a preguntar qué es lo que nos
pasaba a las mujeres en el desarrollo de
nuestra profesión legal y decidimos
empezar a buscar nuestra propia data
entramos página web por página web de
los principales estudios del perú a
contar cuántos socios y cuántas socias
mujeres habían nos dimos cuenta que en
la medida que se iba avanzando en la
carrera éramos menos mujeres de hecho de
la muestra de estudios que vimos en ese
momento 30 por ciento no tenían ni una
sola socia mujer en ese momento nos
dijeron que era porque todavía no habían
suficientes mujeres pero que eso pues ya
iba a cambiar entonces fuimos a ver qué
es lo que pasaba con las facultades de
derecho y nos dimos cuenta que por lo
menos desde el año 2000 ya éramos más
del 50 por ciento de egresadas entonces
esa idea de que no habían mujeres no era
tan cierto
también realizamos los rankings
internacionales que nos dicen quién es
quién en la profesión legal y nos dimos
cuenta que del 2010 al 2017 en las
primeras posiciones del ranking en las
del inicio habíamos pasado de ser 35 por
ciento de mujeres a 55 por ciento nada
mal
pero cuando veíamos las posiciones de
liderazgo del ranking nunca logramos
superar el 13 por ciento era como una
línea muerta en ese periodo
fuimos a ver también qué pasaba con los
eventos académicos y los paneles de
expertos y nos dimos cuenta que ahí
tampoco estábamos
tomamos una muestra de 17 eventos en un
año y vimos que de 204 panelistas sólo
32 fueron mujeres también realizamos dos
números de una revista de derecho para
darnos cuenta que de 62 artículos
solamente 6 fueron de autoras mujeres
evidentemente esto tenía que comenzar a
cambiar y a eso le dedicamos nuestros
comités
el comité de liderazgo se dedicaba
entonces a fomentar el desarrollo de
nuevas habilidades y de networking el de
mentoring a propiciar que la experiencia
de algunas pasan las más jóvenes
el des visibilidad a ponernos ahí donde
claramente no estábamos
el de reglas de juego para encontrar las
mejores prácticas específicas para
nuestro sector y el de medimos a darnos
data información y un recuento de cómo
es que íbamos avanzando
cuando lanzamos o cuando decidimos
empezar uip decidimos también que
queríamos que sea una iniciativa nuestra
que esté basada en la confianza y en la
solidaridad decidimos entonces que
durante ese primer momento no queríamos
involucrar a las empresas en los
estudios de los cuales formamos parte
no queríamos que por ningún motivo se
use uip para competir por supuesto esto
también significó que no teníamos fondos
y teníamos un evento por lanzar en ese
momento tomamos contacto con dos
organizaciones que hasta el día de hoy
son nuestros socios estratégicos uno es
la cámara de comercio de españa que nos
ayudó a lanzar nuestro primer evento y
nos continúa apoyando hasta el día de
hoy y el otro es una revista de negocios
que dos o tres veces al año
visibilizar nuestros avances cuando
lanzamos uip mandamos un poco más de 100
invitaciones
sabes cuántas mujeres abogadas vinieron
parecía un cónclave
yo nunca pensé ver tantas abogadas
juntas con este propósito a la vez era
claro que es ser un tema pendiente para
muchos de nosotros
ese día aprendimos la meta les contamos
sobre nuestros cinco comités y les
pedimos que si querían y podían se
registrarán en alguno de ellos
al terminar el evento 80 de las 86
abogadas se habían inscrito en alguno de
nuestros cinco comités ese día le dimos
vida a estos comités
hoy día somos más de 600 y por supuesto
que la composición de nuestros comités
ha variado entramos y salimos de ellas y
está bien no siempre tenemos el tiempo
para estar y no nos juzgamos por eso lo
importante es que los logros siempre se
cumplen porque ésta no es una tarea de
una sola es una tarea de todas
el día de ayer cumplimos dos años desde
que lanzamos uip y hemos hecho un montón
de cosas
así que si usted es el día de hoy me
preguntan qué podemos lograr las mujeres
cuando trabajamos juntas con un mismo
propósito
yo les digo que esto es lo que podemos
lograr nuestro comité de liderazgo ha
hecho una serie de eventos que han
fomentado que nos conozcamos
profesionalmente pero sobre todo
personalmente nuestro comité de
mentoring tiene implementadas ya dos
promociones donde los vínculos entre
mentor así mentís persisten después de
culminados los programas nuestro comité
de reglas de juego acaba de lanzar un
manual de buenas prácticas en igualdad
de género específicos para la profesión
legal y además lo lanzó en un evento
donde contamos con una participación del
40 por ciento de hombres y miren a su
alrededor eso es bien difícil de lograr
porque cuando se habla de igualdad de
género se piensa que se está hablando de
mujeres y cuando se habla de mujeres se
piensa que está hablando solo de mujeres
como lo hicimos no importa en qué comité
estábamos todas fuimos a buscar a
nuestros socios y a decirles que tenían
que ir y que además tenían que llevar a
otro socio hombre
nos dimos cuenta que cuando íbamos a
tocar la puerta y a otras dos habían ido
antes de nosotros a decir lo mismo y que
a veces una gerente legal cliente
miembro de whip ya lo había llamado a
decirle lo mismo
todas habíamos trabajado con un mismo
propósito
se acuerdan que les comenté que no
estamos en estos paneles de expertos ni
actividades académicas pues nuestro
comité de visibilidad creó quórum que es
una iniciativa que fomenta que las
personas que participan organizan o
financian este tipo de eventos no lo
hagan si es que no hay mujeres en ellas
y nuestro comité medimos ese centro
página web por página web hoy día contó
con el apoyo de la universidad del
pacífico y una encuestadora
internacional y entonces tuvimos nuestro
primer estudio oficial de línea base que
nos da cuenta de cómo estamos las
mujeres en la profesión legal pero
además nos dio algo que no esperábamos
nos dio el primer reporte del impacto de
whip en estos dos años
ciertamente tenemos muchos retos
pendientes pero hoy queremos contarles
nuestros logros
hoy 20% de estudios cuenta con comités
de igualdad 37 por ciento tiene
programas de mentoring 40 por ciento
cuenta con políticas flex time o de
trabajo remoto
hoy
en sólo dos años hemos pasado de ser 15%
de socias a 33% muchas en las cuales lo
fueron mientras estaban embarazadas o
acababan de tener hijos
fuimos dos las que empezaron uip luego
diez
11 hoy somos más de 600 mujeres abogadas
en esta red de solidaridad que llamamos
we perú
la sonoridad es un movimiento del que no
solamente nosotros formamos parte
también están las mujeres energía las
mujeres en minería las que de tecnología
las emprendedoras y las empresarias las
mujeres que forman parte de las juntas
de directorio y muchas otras más
hoy las queremos invitar a mirar al
costado a buscar sus puntos de encuentro
a conectarse entre ustedes a saber que
cuando las mujeres nos juntamos podemos
cambiar las reglas de juego las queremos
invitar a mirar para adelante con
propósito y sororidad gracias
[Aplausos]